hello folks I was in New Orleans last
week and I had the pleasure of
interviewing Laura Ruiz the primary
author on this paper large language
models are not zero shot communicators
now this is exploring the ability of
language models to perform implicature
which I guess from a machine learning
audience point of view you might think
of as being some kind of extrapolation
or even abstractive reasoning there's an
example of this that we can try
Esther asked can you come to my party on
Friday and you won't responded I've got
to work which means no
yeah part of the reason I wanted to do
this quick intro is since this interview
open AI has released a chat GPT which is
pretty impressive actually
so we can come in here and we can
say something along the lines of
Esther asked can you come to the party
on Friday Shuan responded I have to work
does Shuan
can
Joanne come to party
it looks like it has failed it says it's
not possible to say whether zhuan can
come to the party or not because we
don't have enough information
may or may not be able to come to the
party depending on his work schedule and
other factors
oh dear yeah so this is an example of
failed implicature but anyway if we come
over to Laura's Twitter
she posted a little thread the other day
saying that loads of people have been
sending her implicatures which they used
as examples in the paper and apparently
chat GPT does understand some of them
which he's very happy about but she
wanted to write a short Thread about it
so she said before they started writing
the paper she would try lots of
implicatures that she came up with on
DaVinci 2 in different wordings with
moderate success some always solved and
some half of the time depending on the
wording meaning random performance since
the test is a binary which is to say a
yes or a no that's why they decided to
do a systematic test to figure out how
good it actually was and how much it
depending you know how much it depended
on the wording of the prompt and a few
months later they had the answer that it
was okay but not close to humans and
okay means that on DaVinci 2 and 3 the
performance of zero shot implicature is
roughly 70 percent most of the other
models fail even with few shot in
context prompting
so anyway she said that she gets the
people who are excited that chat gbt is
doing pragmatic inferences but she felt
the same with DaVinci too it's all
anecdotal she says but a more systematic
Test shows a significant Gap with humans
nonetheless and it's the same for Da
Vinci 3 and presumably the same for chat
GPT she says that once this implicature
data set gets solved and she has no
doubt that it will get solved relatively
soon since fine-tuning with human
feedback helps a lot they might have
some baseline pragmatics in their models
and that's when it will get really
exciting she says that she's personally
Blown Away by chat gbt's capabilities
it's absolutely incredible at explaining
things compositional generalization of
Concepts simulating AVM I'm not sure
what VM means coherence creativity
writing essays poems and more
she said that the pragmatic language
that they studied is part of a type of
casual language that we use in
conversation that might emerge from
social interactions she's personally
thinking about why human feedback helps
so much and whether interactivity and
social pressures might help even more
anyway enjoy the interview hi it's
lovely to meet you nice to meet you too
so I'm speaking with Andrew lamping them
yesterday and he really highly
recommended your paper I looked it up
it's called large language models are
not zero shot communicators and I also
recognize Stella bitterman and Sarah
hooker of course Sarah is an absolute
Legend now um You Led in the paper by
saying humans interpret language using
beliefs and prior knowledge about the
world for example we intuitively
understand the response I wore gloves to
the question did you leave fingerprints
as meaning no so um you call this um uh
implicature I suppose I would think of
it as some kind of
um extrapolation uh being able to kind
of reuse knowledge that we have about
the world in a different situation but
could you um Talk us through that paper
okay so yeah thank you that was a great
introduction to the paper
um indeed implicatures kind of the
technical term that we use for uh this
example that you gave
and indeed extrapolation is a sensible
way to describe this what we do in this
paper is
kind of showed that large language
models are not really good at this
aspects of communication and we think
it's a very important aspect of
communication so the title says large
language models are not zero shells
communicators right so what we mean by
that is
um to be a communicator you have to
infer the meaning of utterances not only
by their semantics so not only by
how words combine into some kind of
meaning but but by interpreting the
shared knowledge our shared experience
of the world
and that's what we look at in this paper
and what we find is that large language
models are pretty bad at this
specifically we group them into
different groups so we have base large
segments models like opt and Bloom that
are just trained on next word prediction
and we also have instructable models
like fluency5 t0 or DaVinci's DaVinci
instructable models by open AI
and all models perform really bad closer
to random than to humans but
openai's instructable models Have Much
More Much More promise they're much
better at it interesting okay so um now
the the zero shot thing is is very
interesting so we take these models and
it's kind of like self-supervised
learning we train them on loads of data
on on the internet and you're saying
that zero shot is when we don't really
give much information in the prompt so
there's a relationship between how big
the model is and how much in context
learning that we give to the model in in
the prompt yeah that's true yeah the
zero showcase that we tested is we give
the model a short instruction saying
like
um
in the following exchange someone gives
a response that has some meaning beyond
the utterances
um it has the meaning is yes or no can
you resolve this and then we give a an
example
um and then we evaluate it on ways but
based on whether it can choose yes or no
um so that's the zero shot case and
humans we don't give any instructions at
all we just said
um
resolve this to a yes or no okay so is
it the case that large language models
then zero shot almost irrespective of
their size and irrespective of this
human feedback alignment they just don't
perform very well at this implicature at
all the instructable models by open AI
gets a non-trivial performance okay I
think the models like OBT and Bloom
those kind of Base models they really
can't do these Styles very well at all
they get 10 above random but opening
eyes models are yeah around 70 at zero
shards interesting so um did you do some
work looking at okay well let's try um
some in context learning does that does
that improve the implicature definitely
yeah we like it's it's unclear right
whether zero shots is a fair comparison
to humans for these models humans are
primes in different ways so we also
wanted to try a few shots in context
learning and personally I thought in
this case in context learning wouldn't
help much because each indicature
requires a completely novel type of
inference but in fact we show that open
ai's models is the only group of models
that really benefits from this a lot and
they can get to up to 80 performance
with roughly five examples which and
afterwards more than five examples is
kind of plateaus
but there's still like a significant Gap
with with humans but it's a it's a great
Improvement yeah that's fascinating so
can you give an example of if we were
doing some in context learning let's say
with DaVinci too what would that prompt
look like
so if we
um I don't exactly remember the wording
of the of the prompts but there would be
something like the following are
examples of the task and then you get a
bunch of implicatures that are already
resolved to a yes or no and then you get
uh in the original instruct prompt that
says resolve the following sentence to a
yes or no and then you get the actual
example and these in context examples
are well taken from a development set
okay okay so
can you tell us a little bit about how
this reinforcement learning for human
preferences works on language models so
reinforcement learning for human
preferences is a method to fine-tune a
base star signage model so the base
arsenius models are opt and blue for
example that's part of the group and
they are just trying to next word
prediction right but they are not really
aligned there are this alignment problem
where they there are trains on network
prediction and that's not really what we
are asking them to do
um and then with reinforcement learning
from Human feedback what we further do
we I mean not we unfortunately other
people do is they take
um some kind of human preferences from
somewhere like for example humans are
shown fronts and completions by models
and they say this one is better than
that one this completion for the text
for this prompt is better than that one
by that we get a sort of ranking by
preference and we can learn a reward
model on those preferences
with an interesting trick that was
probably since 2017.
and through this rewards model we have
sort of we can bootstrap the preferences
from humans into the base archangus
model by fine-tuning them with regular
RL on these uh on this reward model yeah
it's really interesting um I was
speaking with um SRI Jen uh Kumar he won
one of the outstanding paper Awards and
Europe's and he's got this work on
um kind of we want the models to be more
anthropomorphic and we have these priors
to help us understand the world and he
came up with a framework of kind of like
importing uh these priors from language
encodings into let's say a discrete
program uh synthesis model but um I
guess what I'm saying is that there's
something really interesting going on
within context learning and it's almost
like we're giving the model the priors
to extrapolate or to do something useful
in this particular situation yeah yeah
that's a really interesting I I don't
know the paper I should check it out but
the way I fuse and my my thinking has
been shaped this week also by Andrew
lumpin and who wrote an interesting
paper on comparing models and humans
it's dead it seems that in context
learning produce specific task
implicatures it's not really data that
they learn how to use their shared
experience from the in-grounds examples
their primes for the thoughts with a few
shelter examples in the context and I
think that's actually what's happening
here like if you test the model zero
shots there's no why would we expect it
to you know do this sauce properly
there's no motivation or anything like
that because if you prime it within
context examples it's uh it does better
and that's that would also explain why
it doesn't
help to add more than five examples
because
it's not using sort of the inherent
information in the examples it's just
being primed for this specific to us
that's really interesting Sarah has done
lots of work on interpretability and in
machine learning models and
um one thing that I wrestle with a lot
is whether we should try and get models
to think the way humans do and you can
come at it from an intelligibility and
interpret you know like an
interpretability point of view but you
can also come at it from a
generalization point of view like maybe
we do symbolic generalization over
cognitive price and that's how we
understand the world but there are
people who just say large language
models they're just a different mode of
understanding and we shouldn't try and
make them like us like what do you think
um it's a good question I I am really a
non-expert on interpretability I'm like
I always come at it from a very answer
anthropocentric view like I would love
them to be more like humans because that
would make them interesting subjects to
study also and better to communicate
with but at the same time you can take
this opposite View and I think Stella uh
the co-author a co-author on this paper
often says like you're making a category
area you're attributing something to
these models that they cannot they don't
have knowledge you know like and those
kind of things so it might also very
well be that we're trying to look for
pragmatics or semantic understanding in
these models but that's just not how you
should think about it
and and I completely forgot to ask you
so so again
um just some some of the audience don't
know about natural language
understanding in linguistics and so on
so um what is pragmatics yeah that's a
good question so pragmatics is the the
aspects of uh it's an aspect of language
the way we study language that doesn't
really look at the syntax so how or
semantics
which look at for example those kind of
aspects of linguistics look ads how what
a word means and how you combine them
into novel meetings so those kind of
areas of linguists really look as when
someone understands the term uh the
utterances John loves Mary they also
understands utterance Mary loves John
pragmatics goes beyond that it looks at
how context and our shared experience
really um
influences meaning so usually the
meaning determines by pragmatic
inference is not really directly part of
the the context window you really have
to
um
you know tap into your prior knowledge
yeah so I'm a fan of of Montague as well
so it's almost like we have the semantic
potential and then we have pragmatics
and that's bringing like some some
additional context yeah yeah exactly
yeah okay okay and um because that's a
really great example from you know like
that that extrapolative example from
Montego about Mary loves John
um How could a large language model
realistically because I think of that as
being a symbolic generalization yeah so
how could a language model do that kind
of generalization symbolic
generalization yes oh that's a big one
I don't know I really really don't know
like I I in my research uh journey I can
kind of come from studying
compositionality and language which is
really more uh this type of thing that
we're talking about now and looking at
more sort of neurosymbolic approaches or
stronger inductive biases and now you
know these large language models really
showed us that there are some insane
amount of compositional generalization
going on without any inductive bias for
that uh GPT kind of shows us that with
all these examples on Twitter right so
you give it two novel Concepts and um is
combines it beautifully into some kind
of story
um but yeah to go back to your question
how how can they do it I don't know
maybe scale will get us there to the ex
to the sense that humans are also a
perfect symbolic reasoners like again to
mention Andrew limpina he did a great
paper on a symbolic Behavior yeah where
it's not really uh discrete I can do
symbolic processing versus I cannot do
symbolic processing but it's more a
scale
um does kind of shape my thinking as
well I think it's a scale large language
models are pretty far on that scale they
can do very interesting compositional
generalization
and sort of symbolic Behavior but they
feel in catastrophic ways as well like
again an example that I think comes from
Gary Marcus is when you all set the jet
GPT
um
does a how does horror how do horses
ride Cowboys and it just writes a whole
story about you know how a horse rides a
cowboy even though
it doesn't work yeah it's so interesting
because um I think it's easy to think of
large language models in the binary so
Marcus says they're blaviators and um
and Bender says they're stochastic
parrots and then you and then you have
the folks who think that it's it's
emergent um you know reasoning and
symbolic generalization yeah and I was a
skeptic and I just can't ignore the
evidence they they really are they
really are doing amazing things now yeah
um and and you were just speaking to
lampan and it's a similar thing with
this idea of of you know like um
symbolic generalization it might not be
a binary right yeah exactly yeah yeah it
might be a very greatest competency yeah
yeah and humans also fail in certain
cases
so on this in context learning because
that's something that that has
interested me so um the first version of
gbt3 the zero shot we didn't really know
how to prompt it it looked like a
bloviator yeah we then went on this
intellectual journey and we discovered
front engineering scratch Pad Chain of
Thought reasoning uh I spoke with Hattie
Zoe the other day and she's got this
kind of like algorithmic prompt in
context learning and it's just
remarkable what's going on there so like
do you have any intuition is is it is it
like the prompt is some kind of a
program interpreter or something
my intuition is rather that the prompts
kind of I don't know how to formalize
this intuition but I guess that's why
it's an institution
um that's a promise kind of uh primes to
model and puts it into a sort of area of
its weight space where it can
whereas can
um you know better answer the actual
question that is asked in uh in yeah the
actual question that's us and I think
certain things that point towards this
is that there is also uh some research
coming out where they permute the the
labels in the in the in context examples
and they show that the performance is
similarly good even though at the same
or like they do completely random labels
in in context examples and the
performance is still pretty good but
there's also other work that shows that
that doesn't always work sometimes you
do needs actual labels
um so yeah again the answer is basically
I don't know but my intuition is rather
that the model is really primed for uh
um or there's also another great way of
viewing this
um and I read that unless wrong at some
point but I I don't know how to
attribute all his earbuds because I
forgot their name but it's about
um that these models are good at
simulating anything so you have to sort
of prime them to know let them know what
they're simulating right now
yes wait isn't it because
um
we
um have an anthropocentric view of the
world and we have um you know we're
regentive with individual agents and a
language model is is everything at once
yeah it's almost like you need to give
it a trajectory just just to just to get
it to go somewhere interesting yeah so
um with with this in mind so you know we
really want to make progress in natural
language understanding and what do you
think are the steps we need to make to
you know robustify these language models
yeah that's a good question
um personally from this pragmatics paper
I think pragmatics is one area where
they can make huge strides still I think
even though they have semantic failure
modes they're really impressive at that
they're really impressive at
compositional generalization
um well it's pragmatics might be
something that they're simply not you
know trained for uh currently and one
very low hanging fruit is the rhf that
we talked about
um I think that clearly really improves
that it's and
um intuitively it seems like these um in
the instructivity paper you see that
they asked the human labelers to really
infer the human intents into problems
and ride on and that's very a
reminiscent of implicatures
but then on a more sort of broader scale
I think some kind of embodiment or
interactivity might be really important
like pragmatic inference is really a
social skill that we have there's a lot
of pragmatic a lot of pragmatic
pressures that you encounter while just
acting in the worlds and navigating
communication and navigating a lot of
things so I think I'm currently trying
to look at
a setup in reinforcement learning where
we're trying to do a makeup pragmatic
cells can see when pragmatic reasoning
would emerge there and I and I
yeah I don't know how to consolidate
that fully with large language models
yet but I think interactivity and social
um navigation it's important
I'm really fascinated by um you know the
embedded tradition in cognitive science
and I think there's a lot of interesting
work there but um I I suspect you do as
well a little bit
how do you contrast you know what is
essentially the representation of this
view where everything's in this big
monolithic model to some kind of
relational view where we're using
essentially the world as its own
representation yeah yeah again here I
don't know to what extent it's also
possible to express everything in just a
representation as few where you have an
internal role model and and I don't know
to what extent you really need an
external world to learn but it's
intuitively it seems like that might be
very important and
intuitively it also seems like the the
interesting the behaviors that can
emerge are really limited by the world's
models acting in so a large language
model only see sex
um and there's basic things that just
simply cannot uh learn even though it
has surprised us
um a lot
so I think I don't know it's easy to
think about is in that it's really
important to have some kind of external
world to interact with and um but you
know I I'm happy people are working on
skating and I'm not I'm not saying you
know
some type of AGI whatever that means
might not emerge from Simply
scaling up basically what we're doing
right now
amazing and um are there any other
um you know parts of your paper that we
haven't spoken about
um yeah one thing that we found pretty
interesting is that even though these uh
open ai's models can get really high
performance close to humans six percent
roughly that won't tell you much without
like the details but it's a significant
Gap still but it's really really close I
don't know if a human might
figure out whether this model is a model
or a human you know in that case but
when we sort of drill down and and uh
make its astronomy of the examples that
are in this data says we find that they
are mostly benefiting from the simple
examples and where not a lot of context
is needing so one example is an
implicature is if you ask me how many
people came to your party and then I say
some people came it's really the
conventional meaning kind of of the word
some that I meant not all people gain
but it's still an implicature but it's a
it's a very common one so those kind of
examples if we isolate those and we look
at specifically examples that are really
context dependent like um
um are you coming to uh the open AI
party tonight I have food poisoning you
know those need much more context to be
resolved and then the performance
decreases again and there is roughly a
nine percent Gap
um which like the best model but it's
all other base models and instructable
models like fancy five and stuff they
they then again completely fail on those
kind of examples fascinating I'm really
interested by this idea that
understanding is a complex phenomenon
and we um it's like the parable of the
blind man and the Elephant so we create
all of these metrics and the metrics
exclude most of the truth yeah and the
metrics for pragmatics presumably are in
some sense even more complicated than
the metrics that we already use in
natural language understanding and um it
just feels like is that is that going to
be a serious problem for us to kind of
encapsulate how well the model
understands do you mean that we're sort
of
um
giving it a test that is couldn't really
solve well I suppose one way of looking
at it is in this particular test we've
come up with lots of examples of of
pragmatic inference if you like yeah and
what we're doing is we're taking a very
complex phenomenon and we're kind of
we're putting pins through it so we're
putting like little slices through it in
different angles and and then we've got
this shortcut problem that if we
optimize on any one of those slices we
might be kind of like excluding
everything else that's important yeah so
it feels like we've got I mean is is
this like a gen a general problem in in
natural language understanding it seems
like you're getting at evaluation in
some to some extent right like I think
evaluation is the single most difficult
thing in NLP it's um this is just a
benchmark to give us some intuition as
to what these failure model current
failure models fill your modes of these
models might be and I think if this
Benchmark is at some point passed by a
model that's you know in and of itself
without trying to diminish my own paper
it doesn't as much like there's much
more to be done we need more different
benchmarks we need like human testing
and sort of touring style maybe
um and yeah I think I think this is the
the most interesting problem
um in NLP like how to properly evaluate
uh interesting yeah and do you take an
interest in like fairness and bias in in
the models as well I'm very interested
in it but from a sort of specsaver view
as well like I haven't worked on it at
all okay okay yeah because that's
presumably a massive challenge yeah yeah
yeah definitely yeah amazing um so um in
in the final question like what are you
most excited about you know in in your
research trajectory over the next year
or so
um well definitely I just feel super
excited to be working on stuff like this
currently given the capabilities these
models show like they're they're
absolutely amazing and I love seeing how
people interact with them like the
creativity of people is really needed to
get some kind of interesting response
out of these models right and also the
creativity of people is needed to find
the failure modes and um yeah so what
I'm most interested in uh excited about
now personally for my own research
journey is really trying to look at uh
you know and interactive setup and see
when pragmatic inferences might emerge
in what kind of
um environment what kind of pressures do
we need and and how can we translate
that back to getting to be to getting
like um
language models be zero shells
communicators amazing and where can
people find out more about you
um they can follow me on Twitter his
first name last name and I have a
website also first name last name.com
yeah amazing Laura thank you so much
it's a pleasure to meet you thank you
for having me amazing amazing right cool